Barbara Kellerman is author of bad
leadership what it is how it happens why
it matters she spoke about it recently
at the Commonwealth Club in San
Francisco it's one hour all right now
those of you who have been around the
leadership block a little bit as I have
must be asking yourselves why is this
woman writing a book about bad
leadership what would we want to know
about bad leaders well my answer to you
is why not I am going to start by making
three basic points and the first one
relates to the point I just made this
book is to claim for the leadership
field the bad side those of you who have
any familiarity at all with works on
leadership know that they are nearly
entirely about good leadership how to be
a good leader how to become a good
leader how to grow a good leader how to
develop a good leader in fact the field
of leadership studies has become so
skewed that I argue that the word
leadership now implies typically good
leadership I'm taking a course on
leadership that means I'm taking a
course on good leadership because I want
to learn how to be a good leader but I'm
on a crusade with this book and my
crusade is to suggest to you and the
entire reading public that is going to
read this book that you cannot learn
about good leadership without being
willing to look as Gloria just said at
the dark side I cannot tell you in a few
simple words why it is that my own field
my own colleagues
have been so reluctant to look at the
ugliness of leadership and there is a
lot of leadership that is ugly that is
not very pretty we know that we wake up
in the morning and we see it in our
newspapers we see it on television we
see it on the internet and yet it has
not been addressed and so this book is
to look at the subject of bad leadership
which is every bit as much about the
human condition as is good leadership my
second key point since no one has
written about this subject before whole
I decided I wanted to look at the entire
universe of bad leadership lots of
different kinds of rotten leaders and I
came up I looked at hundreds and
hundreds and hundreds of cases of bad
leadership and I ended up by dividing
them into seven different types and the
heart of my talk in the next few minutes
will indeed be about the seven different
types of bad leadership one other little
footnote I became interested in the
subject some years ago when it dawned on
me that in a world full of ugliness as
well as beauty there was no literature
on bad leadership I wrote a small book a
small essay excuse me
called Hitler's ghost a manifesto the
word manifesto implies what this kind of
talk is about which is I'm here to make
us pitch I'm here to sell you on the
idea that bad leadership studying bad
leadership matters but the Hitler's
ghost phenomenon I left behind in that I
did not want my work to be on the
extremes I wanted to look at bad
leadership hole hence the seven
different types the web what is the web
all about one other problem with my
field my field of leadership studies
which I adore beyond all measure
is that is that it has become
excessively leader centric there's just
one teeny-weeny problem with that you
can't do leadership alone you need at
least one and I'm sure I could all I ask
you all to say the word out loud
you need at least one follower so this
book is not about bad leaders you'll
notice I didn't call it bad leaders I
called it bad leadership the word
leadership implies leaders and followers
interacting in no case was the bad
leader bad alone
he always or she always acted with the
support of followers so the web is about
three strands that intersect in a web
one the leader to the followers and
three the context in which they were
embedded
clever little mess making meaning of
being bad people would say to me so what
do you mean when you say bad leadership
my favorite story in this regard is when
I was some years ago giving a talk on
bad leadership getting into the subject
I gave a talk to a group in New Haven
and I said what I thought was an
incredibly simple statement something
about Hitler being a bad leader no
sooner were the words out of his mouth
and somebody in the audience actually
interrupted me waving frantically and
say no no no Hitler was a very good
leader he was good and that he was
brilliantly effective then and there I
understood I better make my use of the
word bad clear so for the sake of the
book and the sake of the discussion bad
means either ineffective or unethical or
every now and then it means both means
and ends we can't go into this here it's
so complicated but I will tell you that
sometimes a leader and his or her
followers have good ends and rotten
means sometimes they have just the
opposite and sorting that out is a lot
of fun and games
hmm I was going to say the PowerPoint is
not responding as it should
aha okay success the seven different
types of bad leadership number one
incompetent we will go into these in
detail
number two rigid leadership number three
in temperate leadership number four
callous leadership number five corrupt
leadership number six insular leadership
and finally evil leadership if somebody
can control this PowerPoint this is not
working I don't know if we can fix this
while we're talking but I will tell you
that the first if we can make the slide
go faster all nod to you if you can move
the keyboard along good okay if you if
somebody wants to stay there and just
move it up that would be great
I'll signal to you the first kind
incompetent leadership the leader and at
least some followers like the will or
skill or both to sustain effective
action with regard to at least one
important leadership challenge they do
not create positive change my first
example now in each of the different
types for each of the different types I
provide in the book many examples but I
focus on one and in this case a man by
the name of Juan Antonio Samaranch I see
some of you nodding heads in the
audience this man was head of the
international
Olympic Committee for two decades and he
presents us immediately with some of the
complexities about this because he was
in many ways a competent leader but
toward the end of his tenure for his
last five 10 years in office by the way
20 years is a very long time to hang
around but towards the end in this
particular case he was absolutely
oblivious to what was going on around
him he was oblivious to the drugging he
was oblivious in particular to the
corruption that tainted the
International Olympic movement and
taints it to this day he left behind a
legacy of corruption that makes him in
the end an extremely incompetent leader
rigid leadership the leader and at least
some followers notice that followers are
referred to in every single one of these
definitions are stiff and unyielding
although they may be competent they are
unable or unwilling to adapt to new
ideas new information or to changing
times now I'm not going to get political
I'm not going to get current I'm not
going to suggest that anybody that we
know is guilty of rigid leadership
rather I will point to this particular
example a woman by the name of Mary
Meeker just out of curiosity raise your
hands if you know who Mary Meeker is oh
maybe 25% of the audience Mary Meeker is
was what I call an opinion leader that
is she did not hold a formal position of
power and authority as we usually use
the term but when she spoke legions
listened and did what she told them what
did she tell them to do she was a
financial analyst who was a
picker in particular she was a stock
picker during the heyday of
the internet tech stocks particularly
the 90s the late 90s as they went up and
up and up and up the trouble is that
Mary Meeker did not see the times were
changing she stuck with her internet
stocks too long and so the woman who was
known in her heyday as the queen of the
net became the poster child for can we
ever trust Wall Street again the queen
of the net was so rigid that she became
this wanted poster as it were for stock
advisors financial analysts who mislead
legions of stock buyers as the stocks
tanked intemperate leadership the leader
lacked self-control and is aided and
abetted by followers who are unwilling
or unable effectively to intervene once
again where do I choose my examples from
the world is full of intemperate leaders
but I could not resist but focus on this
particular man Marion Barry jr. it's an
easy laugh but an interesting story
Marion Barry was addicted to what I
typically call sex drugs and rock and
roll now what's interesting about this
story is not so much the man not so much
the man because we can call an addiction
an illness so let's for the sake of this
discussion say that Marion Barry was ill
what's interesting is that the voters of
Washington DC four times of
elected him mayor now the first time we
can understand because it was not an
evidence then it really didn't flower
until much later second time harder to
understand third time fairly
incomprehensible that he was re-elected
fourth time absolutely incomprehensible
thus the tale of intemperate leadership
bad leadership you can't get it unless
you get the role of the follower you
don't get it I included this picture of
Miriam berry which was taken just months
ago because he was just recently
reelected
one more time not of course to the
mayoral tea this time but to the City
Council of Washington DC callous
leadership the leader and at least some
followers are uncaring or unkind ignored
or discounted are the needs wants and
wishes of most members of the group or
organization especially subordinates all
right this is a fairly reasonable
picture of a man who would on the
surface of peat appear to be a kind of a
good CEO the man's name is al Dunlap jr.
he was head of Scott paper and he was
also head of Sunbeam but this is a more
telling picture of this particular CEO
who was so uncaring and so unkind and so
mean and so nasty that he could almost
be described as a brutal brutal not only
to those low down and God knows he was
brutal to them but brutal even to his
closest aides against whom he threw such
tantrums that he would literally be
frothing from the mouth you must be
asking yourselves how could a man like
this rise to the top in American
business
maybe we'll get into the answers in the
question period but let me suffice to
conclude with this particular gentleman
by showing you this picture of him it's
the third in the series what's
interesting about this picture is that
it's the one he himself chose to put on
the cover of his autobiography he loved
being called chainsaw al he loved being
called Rambo in pinstripes and this is
the picture of himself that he wanted to
be most known he is of course wearing a
black bandana on his head he is holding
a large handgun in each of both hands
and across his chest in both directions
or leather straps filled with bullets
charming corrupt leadership boring
boring boring so obvious so common so
typical of so much we read the leader
and at least some followers lie cheat
and steal to a degree that exceeds the
norm they put self-interest ahead of the
public interest you'll notice how
cautiously I phrased this to a degree
that exceeds the norm because I assume
most people put self-interest ahead of
the public interest
sometimes corruption is especially
painful to witness and this particular
man is a case in point
it is william aramony show of hands how
many of you know who William aramony is
yes william aramony it pains because he
was head not of a large organization
typical in the private sector but head
of the nation's best-known and arguably
largest charity the United Way of
America so when he stole from the
organization he stole from the coffers
of the needy and the sick
and the poor to whom he was supposed to
be giving interesting story if we had
time we would tell tales in so our
leadership well this one is slightly
counterintuitive so bear with me the
leader and at least some followers
minimize or disregard the health and
welfare of the other that is of those
outside the group or organization for
which they are directly responsible now
before I take you to the next slide I
beg those of you who are Democrats not
to stalk out not to throw things at me
but to just be patient and let me
explain Bill Clinton is my example of an
insular leader but before I get to the
reason why let me explain a little bit
more about insular leadership to me
insular leadership is leadership again
that is so focused on those within the
group or organization that it ignores
the common good or the general welfare
for example in the book I include short
short stories about a man named Lee
Raymond head of Exxon oil
who cares an awful lot about ExxonMobil
about the oil industry but precious
little for the environment I include
stories about leaders in the cigarette
industry who cared a lot about selling a
lot of cigarettes but withheld
information about how cigarettes can be
harmful to your health
so you're thinking well okay how does
Bill Clinton fit into this picture
remember I use the word leadership I do
not use the word leader I am not calling
Bill Clinton and insular leader but I
would argue that this man was
responsible for an incident of insular
leadership which is egregious and
probably some of you in the room
already know where of I speak it is the
case of Rwanda it happens that their
Rwandan genocide which happened in 1994
while Bill Clinton of course was
president was arguably one of the worst
genocides in human history simply
because it was stunningly efficient
800,000 people killed in four months
time that's a lot of killing right fast
now you may be saying to yourselves well
what does Bill Clinton got to do with
what happened in Africa well it's a good
question and I can't answer it directly
except to remind each and every one of
us that the American president bears a
lot of responsibility for what goes on
in the world for better and worse at
that time the Secretary of General of
the United staes betrothed boutros-ghali
he did no better than Bill Clinton Kofi
Annan was in a high position that the
United Nations he did know better than
the other two that I've mentioned nor
did any of the other leaders but this
subject that is Rwanda did come up
during the Clinton administration
neither Warren Christopher nor Madeleine
Albright nor any of them really wanted
to do anything about it
some people in the State Department did
but they were told to be quiet and to go
away four years later Bill Clinton did
apologize the international community
together with nations in Africa must
bear its share of responsibility for
this tragedy as well we did not act
quickly enough after the killings began
we should not have allowed the refugee
camps to become safe havens for the
killers we did not immediately call
these crimes by their rightful names
genocide now that is an apology but
I bet some of you can figure out what my
problem with this apology is it's the
word we it's the word we
it's what ethicists call the problem of
many hands if the responsibility is
collective it's not individual when we
make a mistake and we really want to
assume responsibility for that mistake
it's important that we say aye
I bear responsibility
finally evil leadership
it's amazing how common either evil
leadership is even when defined as I do
very very narrowly with a very high bar
for evil evil leadership the leader and
at least some followers commit
atrocities again the followers are key
they use pain as an instrument of power
the harm done to men women and children
is severe rather than slight the harm
can be physical or psychological or the
harm can be both I wish I could say I
had a paucity of examples from which to
choose this small sampling suggests that
I did not as we sit here comfortably
tonight the world is full of evil
leaders and followers who do their
bidding the example I chose to focus on
is this particular man he was the leader
of the Bosnian Serbs during the war in
the Balkans right of encourage ik is his
name and he's a particularly interesting
case in point because he was not a
leader for very long he's not one of
those people to whom I can point
he was in power too long power corrupted
no he was not because he had another
line of work he had another line of work
he was a physician he was a psychiatrist
is a psychiatrist and interestingly also
a published poet a successful poet this
physician and poet morphed in no time
flat
by all accounts into an evil leader he
is charged with crimes against humanity
as we sit here however instead of being
brought to trial this is the picture the
picture as you see before you is of a
man sitting comfortably on a couch with
a baby on his lap the baby is his
grandson Cora Jack's grandson and
unfortunately it suggests the obvious
the picture was taken just a few years
ago that is well after these crimes were
committed well after he had been
indicted for crimes against humanity by
the war crimes tribunal in The Hague and
still we say we can't find him now I say
we say because the issue of finding
criminals is a hot topic has been a hot
topic ever since 9/11 we're looking for
Osama we're looking for Osama we can't
find him we can't find him we can't find
him this is an example of a man who by
all accounts could be found
NATO hasn't found him he's hiding we
more or less know where he's hiding and
we more or less know who's protecting
him and yet for whatever constellation
of reasons not the Americans not the
Europeans not the NATO countries have
chosen to go out and to get him
I end the book with recommendations I
you can go to the next slide
to because I will not let linger on
these recommendations please note though
that these are recommendations not
necessarily only for leaders in fact
this book is more about followers than
it is about leaders and this brings me
back to the web as I said at the start I
wrote this book as a kind of a crusade
it is my feeling that we cannot begin to
stop bad leadership or even slow it
unless we come to grips with it unless
we look at it and examine it it is as if
a physician would opt for health would
want to keep people healthy but would be
absolutely unwilling to look at
pathology at disease and what you find
when you look very closely here is not
only followers who go along who are in
close but all of the rest of us who are
for good and sound reason bystanders - a
lot of bad leadership we shake our heads
we cluck our tongues but generally we do
nothing so part of my point both of this
presentation and of the book itself is
to argue that if we want to do something
about bad leadership the problem is in
our laps and on our very own doorstep
thank you very much
our thanks to dr. Barbara Kellerman
research director at Harvard's Center
for public leadership at the Kennedy
School of Government and author of bad
leadership for her comments today my
name is Bob Saul dick I am vice chair of
the Commonwealth clubs Board of
Governors I will be moderating today's
audience question period and we have
quite a few questions Barbara so let me
get right to them first question one of
the popular programs on television these
days is The Apprentice Donald Trump what
kind of a leader is he in your opinion
and what about the leadership he's
demonstrating on The Apprentice assuming
that you have watched this as part of
your study
oh no I'm much too intellectual ever to
watch television okay so I'm actually a
fan of the show how many of you in this
room have watched the show okay admit it
at least half of you have it's a rather
lively show and in its first year was
actually very good and it's not even a
question of what I thought about it as
some of you may know it was shown in a
lot of business schools across the
country so people were pointing to the
show and saying this is what's good and
this is what's bad look I don't work for
the Trump Organization and I've never
studied the Trump Organization but I'd
be an idiot if I didn't say the man was
doing something right now we take
pleasure in reading about his Fiasco's
and he has them God knows nobody with
such vaunted ambitions cannot have
Fiasco's I think recently his casino the
part of his whole organization that
deals with casinos ran into considerable
fiscal trouble so the man's not
necessarily a genius but is a remarkable
man a remarkable leader probably how is
he a leader he has a huge organization
which has made a lot of money which has
gotten worldwide attention and on the
show he models a particular kind of
leadership which I have to say
is not entirely without charm this man
has a sense of humor
he has a sense of style so how can
anyone consider him all bad what about
yourself of you as this study made you
into a cynical person do you see bad
leadership every place you look have you
become sort of a conspiracy theorist in
this arena well I think I saw a bad
leadership every place I looked even
before I started writing this book which
is what made me start to write the book
look I am so old that I can remember the
days of Hitler and Stalin now I don't
mean I was around when they were you
know starting their line of work but I
grew up in an intensely political
household and in that political
household some of the Giants of history
were being discussed and as it turns out
to be a giant of history you don't have
to be all bad all good
you can sometimes be all bad somebody
said that the history of the 20th
century was written by a handful of men
and while Churchill was in that group so
was Hitler
and as a student of Russian studies
which as was mentioned earlier I was as
a graduate student at Yale you cannot
study the Soviet Union without coming to
grips with the fact that Stalin was evil
beyond measure under his realm far more
people died than under Hitler's and when
you read about this and you study it you
say to yourselves yourself how could
this happen
it is mind-boggling that a single person
to be sure surrounded by a coterie of
followers could wreak so much evil and
whatever you think for example of Bush's
policy in Iraq if you read what was
written about Saddam before the invasion
before the American invasion you again
shake your head
say how can evil like this persist and
prevail as we sit here it's happening
all over the continent of Africa so this
is not some obscure phenomenon relegated
to the dustbin of history this is our
problem and it is our wonderment that
such things happen in the world ranging
from incompetence all the way to evil so
no I would say that I'm not cynical if
anything I believe as I said at the
start and at the end that the more we
think about this stuff and come to grips
with it the more our collective
consciousness is raised to use a term
that was used in the 60s
consciousness-raising which means to get
us to start to think about this stuff
the more likely it is that we will be
able someday effectively to attack it
one more word if I might Bob I do not
understand why we Americans why people
on the planet are perfectly willing to
attack collectively physical diseases so
we attack heart disease and we attack
AIDS and we attack cancer why is it that
we don't attack what I call this
particular social disease of bad
leadership it is a social disease and it
deserves to be attacked with the same
vigor that we reserved for physical
diseases you are you mentioned the
President Bush and we've got several
questions about President Bush in his
which President Bush our current one oh
maybe one way to encapsulate these
questions would with this following
question this president seems to insist
on total loyalty among his subordinates
would you consider that as a management
expert a warning signal
sure I mean III you know if George we're
sitting here in our midst ooh he should
be you know we should bring him into the
conversation I don't know of any
management expert any leadership expert
who thinks it's wise it's not the
loyalty that's the problem that's not
the problem we all want to be surrounded
by loyal people in our private lives and
in our professional lives that's
understandable what's not very smart and
I think we all know this is to serve for
any of us by the way this is not a
leadership issue for any of us and
particularly leaders and particularly
leaders who wield potentially great
power and great authority and great
influence to surround themselves with
people who do not have the courage who
do not have the guts to stand up and
provide different opinions we need to
have we must have devil's advocates in
our lives so if I say I want to take
this job I have somebody around me who
says no you should take the other job if
the president says I think I want to
invade Iraq we have some people in the
mix some people in the mix who can be
intensely loyal but one way of being
loyal is to offer the other side have
you looked at this have you considered
that what will we do if this scenario
plays out instead of that scenario so
it's one thing to quest for loyalty it's
another thing to quest for yes men and
yes women successful leadership seems to
accrue a good deal of power and this
question says does the power that goes
with successful leadership inevitably
nurture personal characteristics that
ultimately lead to bad leadership
corruption insularity
so forth in other words does power and
leadership form generally corrupt its
owner well that would be really
depressing well we have sitting to our
left a woman who's been the leader of
the common
Club for some time I don't know if that
she would consider being in a position I
particularly note your word Bob
inevitably no of course I mean we'd all
we'd all just throw in the towel and go
home and watch The Apprentice instead of
hanging out here no I do I think this is
inevitable absolutely not
however I think said that do I think
isn't my observation from looking at a
lot of cases of bad leadership that when
you are in positions for a very long
time you tend to get stuck you tend to
lose objectivity you tend to burnout you
tend to get less creative you tend often
to get greedier now what does greed mean
it's interesting the different things
that greed can mean the surface it means
money and we all know how you know we
read the paper and we go you know wasn't
10 or 20 million dollars a year enough
for this particular chief executive did
he or she usually he um did he really
need that additional 10 million in stock
options or 20 million in stock options
so Greed's about money but it's also
about power particularly when you're
looking at the categories of callousness
al Dunlap who by the way made
unbelievable sums of money at Scott
paper and also at Sunbeam even though he
brought Sunbeam down but it wasn't only
about money it's about power it's about
power and if you look at evil leadership
its smote it's absolutely not about
money
it is about extending the domain of
control so the greed is for material
things money the greed is for power and
sometimes the greed is for things like
sex
if you're in a place of power for a very
long time you'd better watch it more
importantly if you're in an organization
however that organization is defined
with someone who has been in power for a
very long time
you as a follower better watch it and
better try to work with other followers
in case you see bad leadership emerging
just one other comment Bob for those of
you who are in situations where you
would even think about doing something
about bad leadership let me give you one
little tip first of all there are things
we can do this is not something this is
not like the rising of the Sun and the
easte bad leadership is not inevitable
so what is to be done one little tip
which I will take just one moment to
articulate bad leadership is far easier
to cure like the common cold if it's
caught early on the more deeply bad
leadership becomes entrenched the more
deeply beneath the surface its roots the
harder it is to uproot so catch it early
if you can
you mentioned greed which brings us to
another question about dennis Kozlowski
the former CEO of Tyco in your book you
described Mr Kozlowski as astonishingly
successful but greedy to the point of
being corrupt so it raises the question
is greed a punishable offense was there
criminal behavior was he was he at the
end of the day a bad leader in your
terminology oh look I think anyone I
don't even want to get into the
legalities of the question Bob but I you
know there is a kind of common sense
approach we can have to all of this if
someone is offensively greedy if someone
seems to want so much money that is so
far
out of our collective realm as to make
us think what is it with this person I
mean this was the man of the 6,000
dollar shower curtain okay raise your
hands in this group how many of you have
a $6,000 shower curtain how many okay
sir I see okay I take it all back I take
it all back when we read about the
excesses of kozlovsky it was impossible
not you know it almost I don't know how
some of you felt but when I read about
it I you know you don't know whether to
laugh or cry it's so ludicrous some of
it that you just go what is this so I
would set aside the legal question and
simply say that anyone who is so out of
touch with the rank-and-file who permits
between him and them that is between
himself or herself as leader and them
the followers in this case let's say the
employees to allow such a wide gap to
happen you'll notice there's agreement
from the gods such a wide gap to happen
that's bad leadership period no matter
how much money the company makes it is
offensive it is not good for morale it
is not good for the audience at large
and stockholders who I'm happy to say
are becoming at least slightly more
active about this kind of thing as our
boards boards which is a whole other
subject we could go into as to why
boards often just go uh-huh uh-huh you
want another five million uh-huh uh-huh
what is that all about why don't boards
take the leadership that they should
take again there are many reasons if we
have time we can go into a few of them
but I would argue Bob that when the
greed is excessive yes that's bad
leadership mr. Kozlowski was accused of
looting about three or four hundred
million dollars but it's always that
darn pesky shower-curtain that
symbol symbol symbols
please comment on executives and CEOs
who are out stood from their positions
and then receive huge severance packages
after they leave what to be done to
prevent bad leaders from benefiting from
profiting from poor leadership it's kind
of a follow on to your previous yeah
well what's happening now with the
Disney Corporation that's a very nice
little case in point as we know most of
us in this room know that Michael Ovitz
for staying with Disney for I don't know
was it a year and a month or something
like that was rewarded so handsomely
that for years and years and years
people put their hands to their face in
absolute horror until it happened that
some shareholders in the Disney
Corporation decided to sue decided to
look into this it is outrageous went you
know it's a vague analog to the
couraging example I showed you one of
the ways of stop you know how do we stop
criminals or how does the society as a
whole try to stop criminal behavior by
threatening to catch people and throw
them in jail if they misbehave now
without going to the into the jail
syndrome here when somebody acts badly
we do not reward them whether they're
bad because they were ineffective or bad
because they were amoral we do not
reward bad behavior we don't reward it
in children we should not reward it in
adults and as long as we keep on giving
golden parachutes to executives who
should be gently ushered out the door we
will continue to have bad leadership
because it pays off you are a professor
and several questions dealt with try to
train our young people with respect to
bed leadership so how effectively are
the business schools teaching students
how to deal with incompetence and other
characteristics of bad leadership well
manifestly not effectively or not enough
look ever since Enron
business schools have thrown up their
hands and said oh my oh my oh my we must
do something and the Business School at
Harvard is a case in point the
curriculum has been revamped revamped
and there's now a major first-year
course that looks among other things at
ethical behavior however there's a sad
truth to this which is that we know that
as educators know very very very little
about how to train for good leadership
whether that's ethical leadership or
competent leadership you know for as
many people who say there's got to be an
ethics course in every business school
curriculum and this should be riddled
throughout the curriculum there is
someone else who says that's not the way
to teach people about ethics you've got
to get them when they're three and four
and five and six years old and the
reason this argument takes place is
because again as I said we don't really
know how to do it look common sense
would apply it can do no harm to talk
about ethics it can do no harm to
acquaint people in business schools and
I'm at a school of government and I
would say the same holds for people in
schools of government with how to behave
ethically but I don't know how you feel
I would argue that there's something
that makes me slightly skeptical about
the capacity of a business school
professor to teach or a professor of
government for that matter to teach a 25
year old or a 30 year old or a 35 or 40
year old about how properly to behave in
your opinion if there was a case maybe
there is about chainsaw al in a business
school where the students come away
thinking that that was behavior they
should emulate because it was so
successful at least for a while or they
should avoid now III think there's
there's nothing about this man anyone
would want to emulate I you know what I
would hope people would come away with
when they read about him is less about
he
then the people around him who tolerated
his misbehavior this is yet another case
that's fascinating as to the his own
excesses but what's equally fascinating
I mean how would you like to work for
someone I mean maybe some of you do but
I bet if you do you don't much like it
who brutalizes you and I mean brutalizes
you on a daily basis how would you like
to work for someone or be in an
organization where you know that from
one moment to the next you can easily be
fired so it's what's instructive about
that case is the reflection back on us
what do we do when we are in a situation
where someone behaves so badly the
argument of this book is that I hope we
do something we shouldn't just take it
we shouldn't just take it we should do
something have you ever had a bad boss a
bad leader and what I now know about
I've been living in Utopia and I've just
never had office
that's a great question what did I do
about it I I will say about academics
that they're actually you know more
autonomous than most other lines of work
but yes I how personal should I get here
oh I try I tried to work I think with
some degree of effectiveness behind the
scenes I did not approach this person
directly I recruited some allies who
agreed with me in the organization who
saw the situation as I did went to a few
key people who I thought would be more
influential with this person than I
could possibly be and things got
somewhat better let me just say another
word about this one - I don't want to
sell you for a moment on the ease with
which one up ends
leadership it's tough it's very hard
work sometimes it's risky it can be
risky in different ways it can be risky
at a low level you get marginalized
sometimes it's risky at a high level
your job can be threatened and sometimes
you could literally be shot so this is
not easy lifting this is not light
lifting up ending bad leadership is
heavy lifting hard work but doesn't mean
we shouldn't try that aren't hard work
again most entrepreneurs bad leaders
because most entrepreneurs are self
focused they're individualistic versus
group oriented this questioner asks you
know I think a lot of leaders are self
self-motivated and self-interested the
entrepreneur it's often said that
somebody who starts a business or comes
up with some kind of creative idea
should not be the one who runs the
business and I think entrepreneurs are
creative in wonderful ways obviously if
they're successful but I would say that
that's not very different from a leader
and leader Lee a leader needs to be
creative and resourceful every bit as
much as an entrepreneur and I think
leaders like entrepreneurs are
interested in the self they you know
some of them are narcissistic in ways
that are absolutely astonishing this a
lot of the leadership rhetoric which
talks about teamwork and collective
participation is just that its rhetoric
in the real world leaders most of them
are very self-involved and think lots
more about themselves than they do about
their followers does that sound cynical
maybe just a tad I would argue though
it's not unlike the real world in the
world real world is bad leadership
determined by the outcome or by the
process under way yeah well that's the
means-ends issue that I talked about
during the presentation the answer I
think is both you know if the means are
really really bad again however bad is
defined
it's bad leadership and if the means are
good
but the ends are bad I mean one of the
examples I talk about in the book is the
example of the Catholic Church where
arguably the ends you know with this
cover-up of abusiveness and so forth and
so on where the ends were arguably noble
ones that is to protect the church but
the means used were not I'm not sure you
can divorce one from the other I think
if the means are bad the leadership is
bad if the ends are bad the leadership
is bad we always hear about leaders
being called unfair that you explore the
concept of simple fairness in your book
I think I explore it I don't use the
word I don't know that I use the word
fair once in the book I do talk about
equity and balance and what is fairness
after all but striking some kind of a an
equitable relationship between leaders
and followers having a contract that is
in the best interest of all and in that
sense I think the book is all about
fairness although that's not a word I
particularly use unfortunately we're
coming to the end of this meeting we
have time for one more question and I'd
like you you to think about with us
whether or not things are getting better
in your conclusion to your book you
describe some of the ways things are
getting better or now I guess you left
with the Khalifa's with the question is
this just another societal problem which
will ultimately be improved on through
training legislation regulation and so
forth or is it like the plague of
mosquitoes which we can swat at one at a
time but somehow they're always still
with us
look I'm not I'm not as I said earlier
I'm not a Pollyanna I think we'll swat
away at this forever but that doesn't
mean that I don't also and this is
probably a good note on which to end our
conversation as I looked around and
thought about this obviously a great
deal
I do think there's a chance that things
are getting somewhat better why do I say
this for example in the private sector
the level of shareholder activism is
absolutely going up shareholders are no
longer quite so willing as they once
were simply to say ok - whenever
management decides in the public sector
I'm in the state of California right now
I don't know if you consider the recall
of gray Davis a sign of citizens being
unwilling to tolerate bad leadership
whatever one thinks of that particular
situation it was an example of citizen
motivation citizens getting it together
to turn away someone in whom they no
longer believed and with regard also to
war crimes tribunals while I pointed to
the case of Radovan Courage ik The Hague
is more active than it has ever been
before in its history in terms of trying
to get some of these people so I think
there is some slight movement in a
positive direction it's not a magic
bullet but as I said as part of my
presentation I am hoping that one part
of this work of combating this social
disease is to raise the consciousness of
a group like this one who thinks hard
about these things and possibly and
hopefully also in creative ways to stop
or at least slow bad leadership our
thanks to dr. Barbara Kellerman research
director at Harvard's Center for public
leadership at the Kennedy School of
Government and the author of bad
leadership for joining us we also thank
our audiences here as well as on radio
and television and now this meeting of
the Commonwealth Club of California
commemorating as hundred first year of
enlightened discussion is adjourned
Barbara Kellerman is research director
at the Center for public leadership at
Harvard University's Kennedy School of
Government bad leadership is published
by Harvard Business School press on the
web at HBS press dot org